what's up everybody its ty here with the
lovely Eric Tay and we just got a
hearthstone on iPad Eric and for people
like me who have no clue what the hell
this game is and why we should care I
wanted to have you maybe explain to me
and launch a lot of other hearthstone
noobs you know why hearthstone is cool
and and why it may be good on the iPad
because I have an iPad okay and I kind
of wanna I kind of want to play it and I
see all you guys in the office playing
it but I don't get it
okay no problem well first and foremost
it's a collectible card game yeah and
we'll just get into a game so you can
kind of see that but I think the biggest
draw now that it is on iPad yes like you
said and for a person like yourself that
has an iPad is that it's in my drawer at
home I haven't used like in a year
okay well now it's gonna you're gonna
brush off the dust and you don't use the
other thing perfect so we'll just go
ahead and play a warrior these are your
standard heroes you have nine of them
each one has a different ability and
each deck of cards has different cards
based on the heroes but we'll go ahead
and play a warrior first here this is a
typical deck it's not a custom deck this
is kind of something you would start off
with if you're first starting there's
actually a nice little tutorial for you
to get into it so you're not overwhelmed
or anything you actually play the AI
first so you'll have I think you start
off with Janna the mage okay soon I said
her name right it could be Jana sorry
what if it's Jana
what if she's like Swedish or something
and then we're all the while or kids
will practice oh but it's I'll get over
it yeah that's one Swedish girls are hot
yeah so right now how is this experience
on the iPad for you versus how it is on
the PC I would say that I think that if
I had an iPad just in the house it would
be way more accessible you know this is
a great game to be playing on the couch
sure on the shoulder I like games in the
toilet yeah I mean this this could this
could be your games could be - give your
game I think that dropping a deuce
playing some harsh thing I think the
time that you would spend would be you
know for a game would be roughly
equivalent unless you you are a quick or
slow it depends that's
good question how long he games last
usually um I think anywhere from around
ten minutes it could be less than that I
mean it just depends on who you're
playing if the person so I should run
the Taco Bell first and then pick up the
iPad and play some hearthstone but
actually if that's how you beat your
stomach if that's how you want to treat
your stomach don't eat fast food kids
there's much better food for you out
there anyway is that when you first
start off the game here you're gonna get
a choice of three cards generally if
you're a second you're gonna get an
extra card because that first person
gonna draw a card but you get to
actually choose if you want to keep the
hand or not or which cards you want to
keep otherwise you could technically
have I could have cancelled them and
like been like oh I don't want that card
and then it'll give me a new card you
can't we do that once though yeah you
can only do that once in the beginning
the coin is extra mana which is what you
spend to cast your cards got to play
your cards and your mana reserve is in
this bottom right corner here near this
Griffin got it
and each turn you'll gain a crystal and
that all allow you to cast certain
things so like this fiery war axe for
example is a two mana cost and so we
can't play that until we get to mana but
because of the Manics wait go back to
that card where the numbers in the
bottom left me yeah so the three is the
three damaged good and the two is to
durability for this weapon because it's
a weapon whereas like or you could treat
it like life durability or life gotcha
um so I could technically play my
crystal and play a creature depending on
what you want to do or you can pass the
turn okay um since he all he did was
play a blood him I'm gonna pass the turn
so I'm not gonna hurt you yeah he's not
gonna do anything yeah and conserve the
mana that could be more of a non new
tactic Vance yes it could be a slightly
more advanced tactic to be a little bit
more patient gosh yeah um but like I
said when you first start playing you're
probably not gonna get penalized you get
matched up against a player of similar
level and of course you're gonna still
have to go through the AI okay so you're
gonna have to play a lot of different
this but this transcends well on a touch
device obviously it looks like I mean it
looks like it works super well with just
interface filling up cards up there the
menus all look like pretty clean yeah I
mean when I when when I first heard
about this game I thought it would come
actually the iPad first okay potentially
even though you know Blizzard is a very
PC centric type business because it just
resonates so well on the iPad because
you know like you said it's easy to just
drag and drop your cards you know it's
you just carried in your hand it's not
graphic intensive you know it's
something you want to be able to play on
the go on the couch before you sleep on
the [ __ ] wherever you end up wanting
to do especially on the sugar sure yeah
endorsed by games about here yep so now
we have Billy manna okay so I can use my
coin here okay and I can play this
dragon dragon Ling mechanic now
basically we obviously don't have much
using the hand gestures on the iPad but
those who know of an iPad if you haven't
been living under a rock for last seven
half years you know exactly how these
these news of work yeah you just drag
and then you want you drop it where you
want to either on the opponents hero or
in the opponent's creatures
the only difference though from the PC
for people is obviously some people play
click click like I play on a PC and I
click and then I click on the surface to
be like okay I'm gonna play my future
there here you actually have to drag
drag and drop got it but that's not it
not too big of an issue so I just saw
there was little bit of a battle there
yep so there are certain cards like this
elven Archer who come in with battle cry
okay battle cry is basically once they
come into combat they will do whatever
the battle cry is so in this case he did
one damage to my whop wing which was a
2/1 okay so it killed it essentially and
he also buffed his wood Walker here so
now it's kind of like there's a ton
taunt is a defensive type creature where
you actually have to attack the tonk
creature instead of the hero unless like
you have a spell you got a gmail from
Eddie from Eddie
makuu hi Eddie our news aren't what you
said or anything break the half life 3
happen what's going on I have no idea
hopefully not so I mean to wrap this up
obviously you don't have to explain to
me the whole game because I'm sure like
there's a great tutorial if you said
that I can go online you read it however
I do think for people like myself
don't know what hot stone really is and
have never played it I think this is at
least to me a much more accessible way
to pick this up and play it I can sit on
my couch I get up and I have L to you on
my iPad as well so I know you need Wi-Fi
I need yes to be online service for this
that's fine but but even on planes now
planes have Wi-Fi so I mean technically
you probably build a place anywhere
pretty much I mean as long as you're in
ER as long as your Wi-Fi or your
connectivity is stable you'll be able to
play um and I don't think it's gonna
require a lot to to play this game again
like you said it's gonna be easy to
travel with on the plane on the go on
the bus there's gonna be like you know
now there's a new new game to play on
the bus instead of you know bravely
default or something like that but um
yeah it's gonna it's I think it's gonna
be a hit and you know it is free-to-play
yeah so into it yeah so the game I mean
I know there's in that purchases and
stuff like that but the game is
completely free which is awesome yep and
you can do everything pretty you can't
fight you can't fight free you can't
complain about free I'm sure some of you
will complain about for you but whatever
well Eric you got an email from Devon
what's Devon saying I don't know some
pretty high default 360 version blahs
injury oh cool
well anyways Eric I appreciate walking
me through it and obviously this when
does this come out in the States I
believe it's the third and the reason
why we have it now is because of
Australia Canada have it first time I
first I believe I might be mixing up my
countries but I think those two may be
there well if you live in Australia or
Canada you're probably already playing
this if you live in the States
you'll be playing soon thanks Eric Thank
You ty later later
you